hello and welcome everybody to the
cornell hemp field days
my name is jacob toast and i'm a phd
candidate in larry smart clap and today
i'll be talking
about molecular breeding of hemp
for my talk today i'll be discussing
some of the
theory and ideas behind molecular
breeding attempt
and give an example of how we're using
molecular breeding in our research
program to develop a high-yielding
fiber cultivar that has low levels of
thc
to stay compliant as well as produces
high levels of cbd
it is important to recognize the
contribution of genetics and environment
to your trait of interest
for any breeding endeavor so how the
plant grows
the phenotype is there about there's the
result of both
the genetics of the plant as well as the
environment
the genetics of the plant also known as
the genotype
refers to the dna of the plants
the genes and other dna which make up
the plant's genome
so many important traits such as yields
are heavily influenced by both the
genotype and the environment
but some traits such as photoperiod
dependence and cannabinoid
are heavily influenced by genotype alone
concerning photoperiod dependence if you
look at this picture here
the small plant is photoperiod
independent and started flowering
almost immediately after planting while
the larger plant
which is fully period dependent didn't
start flowering
until the night length hit a certain
threshold
so another important trait that is
influenced heavily by genotype
in cannabis is cannabinoid type and
breeding for cannabinoid type is a
fundamental part of any hemp reading
so what is molecular breathing so
in molecular breeding very broadly
instead of just looking at the phenotype
of the plant which is the result of both
the genotype and the environment
you look at the actual dna
so advances in molecular biology have
allowed
much easier analysis of dna
and because the dna is the same in every
cell
of a plant whether it's young or whether
it's old
being able to assay a plant just by
looking at the dna allows you
to look at certain traits before they're
even expressed
for instance to determine if a plant is
going to be male or female
or if it's going to produce mostly thc
or mostly cbd
[Music]
so with molecular breeding you can
develop new cultivars based on the
genotype alone
and when done accurately this can result
in less expensive phenotyping and
ultimately reducing the cost
and reducing the time it takes to
develop a new cultivar
now i'm going to talk a little bit about
how our research group is using
molecular breeding to develop
new elite high-yielding fiber cultivars
that have compliant levels of thc
in 2019 we grew several varieties for
grain and fiber production
including two cultivars from china
called bama and puma
we didn't know much about these
cultivars when you first planted them
aside from
a little blurb for puma which claimed to
have
high cbd seeds high leaves and flowers
output
when these plants are grown we were
quite impressed by the plants
in that they had extremely large leaves
and extremely fast
growth rate and would routinely hit 10
feet tall
when we harvested these plants and
breaded them to measure the fiber yields
we found that dama and puma had nearly
doubled the biomass yield of other elite
cultivars grown for fiber
because of this we thought that puma
would make excellent fiber cultivators
however when we looked at the
cannabinoids
we found that both puma and bama
produced
thc at levels exceeding 0.3
and would be non-compliant in
the modern regulatory framework
we looked further at the cannabinoids
that huma and bama were producing and we
found that they were relatively high in
cannabinoids
with puma producing a little over 1.5
percent
total cannabinoids and dama sometimes
exceeding 2
total cannabinoids this is considerably
higher than
what other fiber cultivars produced in
terms of total cannabinoids additionally
we sampled these plants when they were
just starting to flower
so we hypothesized that as the plant
became more mature
the total cannabinoids would increase
even further however the big problem was
that puma and bama produced
thc as a major cannabinoid which isn't
what we wanted so ultimately
what we would like in a cultivar would
be something that produces as much dry
biomass as puma and vama but instead of
producing
thc produces cbd
and to achieve that goal we turn to
molecular breeding
so to understand what we did for
molecular breeding it's just
important to understand the different
chemotypes that are found in cannabis
so there are three important chemotypes
that i'll talk about right now there's
type 1 which is
mostly thc there's type 2 which is cbd
to phc
about a 2 1 ratio but this number can
vary
and then there's type 3 which produces
mostly cbd
so if you're growing a population or a
cultivar
for cbd you'd expect all the plants to
be type 3
but in 2018 and 2019 we found that some
of the plants
that we were growing were in fact type 2
or even type 1 producing almost no cbd
using this data and this figure in the
top here shows
data from 2018 we developed a molecular
marker which looks at the dna of the
plants and can distinguish
type 1 from type 2 and type 3 planets
so getting back to bama and puma when we
were looking at the thc to cbd ratio
for these plants we saw that it was
about a 2 1 ratio of cbd to thc
which would suggest that most of the
plants that we were sampling
were type 2 so an interesting thing
about these type 2
plants is that they won't breed true
if there's a population which is freely
inter-crossing with a lot of these type
2 plants you'd expect to see
a certain number to be type 1 and a
certain number to be type
3. so we didn't have the
hplc the chemical data on a lot of
different
plants from bama and puma we were just
looking at pooled samples
but we could apply this molecular marker
to
these populations and distinguish the
different plants
that were in these different chemotypes
so late last year around december we
grew about 100 plants each of bama and
puma and tested them with this marker
that we developed
and as expected we found that about half
of the plants
were type 2 and we found that about a
third of the plants were type
3 and then the remainder were type 1.
so what we did was we selected the type
3
and in theory these plants should form
an excellent basis
for a high producing fiber cultivar
that produces mostly cbd
however after selection of these type 3
plants
we run into a few problems with their
propagation
so these plants which are so vigorous in
the field were also very vigorous
in a greenhouse and they grew extremely
fast and extremely tall
sometimes in excess of 14 feet they were
also
quite susceptible to various greenhouse
pathogens such as thrips and spider
mites
to make matters worse they appear to be
very photoperiod dependent
and did not flower in the greenhouse in
the spring when we were growing them
there were also some issues with cutting
propagation these plants form a very
nice single stem as you can see in this
photo here
but it's not always simple to take a
cutting and root
that very nice stem so to address this
we're attempting to grow the plants in
the field we've planted them out
and hopefully we'll harvest some grain
at the end of the season which will form
a good basis for scale-up
and we've also sent the cuttings of
these plants
to a collaborator in florida who should
be able
to grow the plants without any issue
in summary molecular breathing involves
selection
on the genotype on the dna directly
family and puma two cultivars from china
are high biomass producers but they
produce high
non-compliant levels of thc
selection in bama and puma for chemotype
3 plants using a molecular marker should
produce
a high yielding compliant fiber cultivar
these plants here growing in the field
in new york
should form the basis of a new compliant
fiber cultivar
we hope to harvest the seeds at the end
of the season scale them up
ensure that the resultant plants have
the same biomass
potential as their parent bama and puma
populations
and eventually potentially release new
cultivars